l'application des 35 heures dans les
entreprises modifié à l'évidence le
comportement des français qui aménage
différemment leur temps de loisirs parmi
les premiers effets quantifiable le
calendrier des vacances ou des week-ends
et différée ou allongés peggy leroy et
dominique marault tel le sable fin et le
soleil pour oublier la grisaille du
quotidien mais pour mettre les voiles
les français n'attendent plus les congés
d'été ou d'hiver place aux 35 heures les
week-ends s'allonge et prennent des airs
de petites vacances
le client n'a que l'embarras du choix
les agences de voyage proposent des
catalogues entier d'escapades de deux ou
trois jours
à moins de trois heures de trajet on a
maintenant beaucoup l'ont avec
l'eurostar mais entendu avec le thalys
amsterdam bruxelles bruges ça marche
aussi très bien et puis j'irai l'europe
du sud avec l'espagne
les billets se vendent donc comme des
petits pains et à longueur d'année en
2000 pour la première fois il s'est
vendu plus de voyages en avril qu'en
juillet ou en août et pendant que les
français se prélassent au soleil
les agences de voyages ne se soit pas
les mains pour autant elles attendent la
fin de l'hiver pour savoir si les 35
heures seront bénéfique ou néfaste les
courts séjours pourrait tuer les longs
voyages plus rentable si les courts
séjours viennent s'ajouter un bon
trafics divers long courriers c'est une
bonne affaire
si les courts séjours consomme une
partie du trafic long courrier que nous
avons vécu jusqu'à maintenant c'est une
mauvaise affaire
la sncf en revanche est loin de
s'inquiéter au printemps les tgv se sont
remplis dès le jeudi soir une
performance réservé auparavant au
vendredi les départs en week-end se sont
multipliées certaine ils sont arrivés à
saturation
il a fallu réagir de plus en plus de
trains circulent vendredi dimanche et
jeudi
et puis la deuxième chose c'est une
innovation pour l'été prochain on a
décidé de faire rouler certains tgv de
nuit pour que des clients qui trouvent
pas de place
et quand même une solution de voyage le
jeudi le vendredi et le dimanche
grâce au temps libre supplémentaire
les français changent leur manière de
voyager des nouveaux modes de
consommation auquel les entreprises
doivent s'adapter